Guatemala is known for a lot of things
coffee
avocados but more than anything else it
should be known for chocolate this is a
place called choco la it's known for
rain and fertile soil which means it's
an ideal place to grow cacao the main
ingredient in chocolate the ancient Maya
grew at their 2,500 years ago and people
are still growing it there today
my number is Victor alpha del Diaz con
mi trabajo es cultivar cacao Gracia can
Chocula trabajando la tierra ferment amo
sell cacao le damos el punto para que
esta listo para el comercio para poner
lo en los tires day process a me n toda
choppa la p el tiempo que nos Evo al
cacao desde la samia hasta la próxima
es un tiempo largo nosotros comemos
nuestra Samia de la coaches a las casas
de camões enosis Imperial was taunted
Largo de Cinco años so after the cacao
is grown it's off to the chocolatiers
brenda is a fourth-generation
chocolatier she makes her chocolate the
same way her great grandmother used to
back in the day and now she's teaching
her children to do the same mean on days
Brenda in Soweto live a second you are
with chocolate it definite a Punto
importante para my chocolate a vasila to
stop but at Osteria cacao is que mucho
mejor que silicon flavor delay Nia no
fuego fungus to Vegas no or no when lo
mismo it
sabor kill it the toast a doll
grandmother cacao as in the local Linea
is this simple a given name
muchas personas buscando algo diferente
ESO lo que nosotros queremos herself
Darla's algo diferente a las personas
que non quaint rang in Hawaii lo que
aqui no certain spoon
this is Fernando he's a newer
chocolatier taking a more modern
approach to Guatemala's chocolate
Renaissance mr. su cuerpo donde a la
pasta de cacao say transform and
chocolaty against Al MacInnis assume
process of Lent
he returned a facility nosotros aqui
trehalose una tony la Mettrie cojones so
it wasn't an aspirin in his deposits in
chocolate what the motive is time
delicioso political acceptability paula
mera video idea yes a lot curricula my
or pardon me da biggest a las Pasillas
and a chocolate assume not be any
limited k ramos que es importante
montaner esto tradición vive por que no
se hace con mucha historia y el cacao
cultivation Guatemala lo que Cano samos
case una con el mundo el chocolate is
assume a chocolate else and I hinted
will be yo Cola P is Guatemala Tikal
[Music]